in the months leading up to your CPAC we
signed on for the second year as a
participating organization and there are
some people who decided that they would
for grab some attention and staged a
boycott and they're boycotting CPAC
because we're gay we've had this
controversy leading up the story now is
about a United conservative movement we
don't care for the homosexual movement
we believe it's a denial of nature and
we don't want to see it and we don't
think that if you're really a
conservative you're really for the
American traditions and so forth did
you'd want those people here yeah but
that's that's not our decision the
decision was do we come and do we not
come we said we come today here and the
newspapers the argument of at CPAC has
been about social issues I mean what do
you guys think about that maybe you
steer clear
we'll definitely avoid that outside our
realm we're actually one issue and this
is it right now what do you recommend to
to gay and politically active people who
are limited government
well fine limit government but there's
more to life than government you got a
moral code to follow my values you know
you know give me my sense of what's you
know sexually moral however I don't
think it's a political issue and I
really think that people who believe in
the smaller government and maximum
individual liberty need to come together
and work together
I'm not going to boycott it because of
that so yeah
it's gonna yeah I'm not hitting on you
by the way marinade
why as a libertarian are you here what's
what's going on well one of the things I
think is interesting about CPAC is that
I've been coming for many years and it's
clearly become more libertarian over
time how do you find being at CPAC which
is obviously can be hostile libertarian
ideas attacked yeah this is my first
year at CPAC and I'm actually surprised
just how many Pro Liberty people I found
wearing campaign for liberty buttons and
yal stickers and that kind of thing so
are already feeling a little more
accepted than I even expected to how do
they keep them on the issues that older
consumers care about but you do need
those new young cohorts of people to
come along and they're already
libertarian and they're all homosexual
lists who's smoking marijuana not all of
them but they're at least friendly to
gay people and they're don't believe in
locking up people who got marijuana did
you by the way he was about to knock you
believe he's not friendly he's a beer ol
days an old guy are you finding that
there's there's sort of more attraction
to your message now and the sort of post
Tea Party world absolutely I get asked a
lot what do you think of the Tea Party
what are these other movements I said I
think this is terrific look at all those
people they got off the couch and when
those people get off the couch they go
to these meetings and they run into
somebody in the Birch Society handsome a
DVD has of a pamphlet or a book or
something like oh now I understand this
and this no tell me more communists had
I as the president whether he wants to
go every single inch of that way or only
a few more miles that way what would
every inch of that way be North Korea
yeah I suspect he would not want to be
North Korea you suspect you're not sure
though well I'm not gonna go into his
head and tell you exactly what he was so
what is the issue that you give a rip
about take no prison the the biggest
issue that you give a rip about and they
don't give a rip about our
whether it's not one big issue there is
there's not and and I named most of them
here is government one thing is totally
out of control
was President Eisenhower communists no
did he help the Communists did he do
everything possible to make it easier
for them absolutely Trump are you here
because you're running
Republican let's see what happens Donald
Trump is coming to CPAC because we asked
him to is Donald Trump gay haha
I think I think he has a pretty pretty
uh
his records out there on his sexual
orientation not well I slept with him I
was just wondering if I was gay because
you know when I did it was very say well
that's the first thing I've heard it's
got this the word Sodom has an
interesting derivation you probably know
it right God rained fire and brimstone
on Sodom and Gomorrah for the purpose of
letting the world know that he didn't
like the homosexual you know you are
about 20 feet up from the booth so if
there's going to be raining down
brimstone you're gonna get hit you
understand no no God the God knows had
it in pinpoint he can pinpoint okay rich
Society is going to be spared by God we
like to think that we're on his side we
hope we hope we don't we measure around
me well we'll see we'll see how it goes